[Music]
6 25 and your friday morning we've got a
message for you from the top of the
construction project food chain
up where the 95 meets the northern 215
beltway you know what we're doing
we're going
centennial bowling
so we're only a couple of months into
the three-year-long final phase of that
project going to be plenty of delays
detours headaches before all is said and
done
so nevada department of transportation
director christina swallow's got some
words of encouragement for the long road
ahead
this project is focused on keeping
motorists safe while providing them
better access to the northwest las vegas
valley
by reducing vehicle idling this project
will improve air quality
i want to thank our ndot team members
and our community partners
whose hard work commitment and
dedication
continues to make nevada safe and
connected
and we're going to continue to keep you
posted on all the developments along the
way they got an incredible website you
can get to from our website
for the 100 000 plus drivers that go
through that area every day
hang in there and especially today be
careful in the rain
buckle up drive carefully and you've got
to put on that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic eight eight news now
dot com